il est là il est avec nous comme tous
les mercredis je vous propose
d'accueillir marc-antoine le bret de
trinité alors on en a parlé dans
l'émission la semaine dernière est sorti
le classement des présentateurs télé que
les français aiment ou détestent et
aujourd'hui tous les lauréats sont là
comme par exemple stéphane plaza qui a
été élue présentateur le plus
sympathique
c'est quoi et oui voilà on va donner les
bons payeurs
ce qu'il a sur l'île d'aix bosch france
tout à l'heure et le meilleur c'est lui
qui me fait quand ils me regardent marc
antoine bouhey ce jour personne n'a rien
dit c'est bon il les a et bien voilà
engagé pas menti en aura voilà voilà
voilà voilà voilà eh bien on va recevoir
tout de suite marque au tableau vert
on a parlé dans l'émission la semaine
des présentateurs télé que les français
aiment ou détestent et aujourd'hui tous
les lauréats sont là comme par exemple
jean luc reichmann inquiète un des
chouchous des téléspectateurs c'est quoi
votre secret jean-luc les audiences est
tout de suite là que sur coup la
question est où c'est la fameuse
question qu il a sur son français
pourquoi même t-il tous à réponse à
cause de bons d'émission puisque les 12
coups de midi les hommes rêvent de les
boire et les femmes est de les prendre
la commerciale on passe maintenant
présentateur que les français trouvent
les les plus impertinentes et vous en
faites partie laurent ruquier bonjour à
tous en effet cyril je n'ai pas peur de
provoquer berges voudrais revenir sur
les rumeurs selon lesquelles vous auriez
une relation avec une grande gueule de
l'émission du coup la question qu'on se
pose alors gilles verdez c'est un bon
coup cyril hanouna vous aussi vous êtes
dans le classement des présentateurs les
plus provocants ça vous paraît justifiée
antoine de caunes tout à fait bon cher
cyril hanouna
car avec le grand journal je suis le roi
de la pertinence en effet c'est très
impertinent en moins de deux ans de
diviser par deux le nombre de
téléspectateurs l'émission ci est très
pertinent bercy et nora qui est très
pertinent c'est manquer de pertinence
alors on peut dire que je suis l'homme
le plus impertinent de france tiens je
viens encore de perdre des
téléspectateurs
tu dois aller on accueille maintenant le
présentateur jugé le plus impertinent de
tous et yann barthès salut à tous et oui
cyril je suis l'animateur le plus
impertinent du prof
il faut dire que je n'hésite pas à dire
la vérité même si elles fâchent par
exemple votre émission
ce n'est que des déguisements et des
perruques ou
les gags aller tout de suite dans le
petit journal
un sketch d'alex lutz et bruno sanchez
habillé en catherine et liliane et
ensuite eric et quentin grimé en
joséphine ange gardien et julie lescaut
c'est moderne et branchée on aura
d'ailleurs yann barthès et là ça vous
savez pourquoi j'ai dû en aura sept
barthez parce que je pense qu'on va
parler maintenant de quelqu'un de michel
drucker alors michel alors c'est
n'importe quoi sont là j'ai dit ce que
vous êtes vous êtes jugés parmi les
animateurs les plus ennuyeux est démodé
et parmi vous donc à michel drucker ça
vous fait de la peine michel ou pas il
était long commencement alors mon cher
cyril j'ai beau être toutes les semaines
dans vivement dimanche sur france vieux
et ne voit pas comment les gens peuvent
me trouvais ennuis al canton côté démodé
impossible puisque ce dimanche encore je
reçois trois espoirs du cinéma français
jeanne moreau michel galabru et line
renaud
les plus démodé on trouve aussi jean
pierre foucault et culture et mon frère
cyril je ne peux pas être démodé puisque
je suis encore à la télévision chaque
semaine pour présenter le loto un jeu
dans lequel je vous le rappelle on peut
gagner jusqu'à 150 millions de francs
pour me soutenir
envoyez donc vos messages sur mon site
36 15 4 foucault merci allez on enchaîne
avec un des animateurs que les français
trouvent les plus antipathiques c'est
benjamin castaldi qui vous embarque pour
benjamin cool à la mouche d'asile et je
suis pas du tout d'accord je suis
absolument pas antipathique et ceux qui
pensent ça c'est ce qu'ils ont à dire
dans les yeux et qui ont du caca dans
les humains je le mets vous dis à tous
ceux qui ne m'aiment pas eh bien je les
emmerde
et puis tiens les autres aussi
d'ailleurs je vous emmerde tous moreau
je t'emmerde
mais en je t'emmerde le monsieur là bas
ils acheminent jeu démodé je t'emmerde
aussi hanouna je t'emmerde aussi voilà
comme ça y'a pas de jaloux voyez bien je
suis sympa et pour terminer on accueille
le présentateur que les français
trouvent le plus drôle c'est michel
cymes bonjour cyril c'est vrai que grâce
à moi les français ont découvert que
médecine et humour peuvent faire bon
ménage d'ailleurs est ce que vous
connaissez la différence entre une
cystite et des bonbons acidulés non y en
a pas dans les deux cas ça pique les
lèvres sinon
obama
cyril est ce que vous connaissez le
point commun entre un patient atteint de
gastro entérite et un candidats de top
chef qui doit faire une pâtisserie dans
les deux cas s'ils n'ont pas drôle au
ils sont bien dans la merde et enfin ce
que vous connaissez la différence entre
la grippe et amélie de secretstory y en
a pas elles sont toutes les deux très
facile à attraper
à paris